what up Brandon would up the yellow I
got a debate club for you
we're here at hundred mile in new york
taste the country we got country girls
or rave girls oh [ __ ]
i'm she will stiff with the twerk she
was twerking like you're the [ __ ]
jackhammer that the back is tight oh
yeah she got that came her booty man
let's watch the butt shake again if you
don't mind now it's a little country
girls or rave girls it sounds like
you're mad at it man I'm not mad at that
at all I'm just saying I'm used to
WorldStarHipHop twerk videos they're a
little looser in there yeah well also
those this girls seem more fit those
girls are more fat a lot of times on
worldstar here you really yeah why are
they fat dude fat fit I got fat fit okay
fine fit bodies broke this she has that
I will say that she has that kind of
like that strong female rabbit type of
flex yeah it's a it's a quick rabbit
hitter back there not too loose like I
don't know she's the best salsa dancer
right okay so no salsa but it should
drop that two-step hitter on you though
oh that pico de thio two-step can we
watch again yeah two-step I don't know
the rest of the words girls that's that
stiff old Home Depot rhythm brother yeah
that's that sexy ass at home Home Depot
ooh but here's the thing country girls
or rave girls country girls all day bro
all day girl they'll take care of those
Southern Belles make you a pie make some
lemonade on the side oh nice
just that honey drip skin oh yeah that
honey drips can read like a serial
killer at a bakery get you a Jenny Jenny
was from the south
who's Jenny Forrest Gump raging hormones
over her life but then when she decided
to be a southern belle who's never shot
the best
well she had HIV yeah said HIV dude I
think I know she had AIDS it doesn't say
that she died at the end she died she
died Jenny died dude remember yes part
of the movie yeah no [ __ ]
I don't watch the end of that movie I
usually stop it about
hour and 55 minutes and three hour movie
so you stop it right when he discovers
Apple huh yeah I stop it when the
party's going strong I feel you you know
I'm out there at the end when he's got
the kid and the kid has a handicaps and
everything dude also rave girls I'm not
trying to be up all goddamn night on
cocaine ecstasy it's no [ __ ] Diplo
with seven other dudes by now but I
thought I thought bond I thought it
sweating yeah I like girls when the
weekends over they go back to work or
school yeah rave girls are a lot of
times they here's the thing they don't
also take care of themselves up they
don't eat they got all these necklaces
on and they all they're dressed up like
a lot of Rainbow Brite addicts they got
a [ __ ] IV drip of Monster energy
drink right into their veins and [ __ ]
yeah and they'll have yeah a lot of
these rave girls - they're doing unique
stuff like you'll see them you know
dipping their arm these pawns these
tampons and new uh
you know MDMA and stuff like that and
for Japan they call it when you're
tripping through your vagina the
dripping the chip in pagina the other
thing is is they kept me can never just
chill yeah it always just be like crazy
color yeah how about a white or black
[ __ ] it's always like a giant neon a
neon green a hot pink a hot purple yeah
like somebody beat yeah it's always like
yeah it always feels like they all look
like mascots of the [ __ ] Toronto
Raptors like yeah I look weird all the
time just being normal you get the shoes
of the huge platforms on them like this
big yeah they look like one of their
parents was a highlighter that's what
they look like a lot of times it looks
like both their parents were [ __ ] then
were two highlighters you see them in
the you see them usually in the lobby in
Las Vegas and they're all like they're
covered in there they're like usually
have like a bunch of like rabbit ears on
and they're dressed like half of a koala
and uh and then they're also been crying
but there's been the sweating and the
dehydrated also getting dehydrated
didn't have a slight layer of
parking-lot dust on them here parking
lot fairies is what I call a parking lot
fairies now with that said very sexy
women
okay now the country girls you get them
out there they got the boots on you know
they're a little bit
or the songs are a little bit more like
camaraderie a little bit more
family-oriented
you know you might um you know you might
see at it but you might not yeah they
might make you wait before you get
married you know I'm saying
yeah the ravers you'll see two girls out
there chewing on each other's tongues
until they literally have eaten each
other's faces off and you're like oh
this is a party yeah ravers be doing so
many drugs they might just eat your dick
off oh yeah I don't want that man and
they'll do that too in the morning oh
they think the world just runs 24 yeah
no idea they think everything's open 24
hours a day
yeah and the country girls shut it down
because they got to feed their kids in
the morning we got a cooking [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] country girls all day gang brah
um seventy-two percent of the audience
agrees with you I feel like rave girls
is going out of style that's now that's
the thing rave girls is going outside if
you're still being her if girl then I
respect it you're a late bloomer
I am too dude I still do a lot of things
that other people gave up on years ago
but um I stopped hogs yeah what's up but
if you're The Rave things over in the
rape thing is go home if you're still
raving you're a drug addict basically
you you just mean drug addict and I'm
sorry you mean hang out your friends
doing drugs late into the night playing
music doesn't work man Oh minik' hole
will climb out of that bitchin and put
on some Jason Aldean
back up my broccolini
get your life together I'm not touching